you want to prove you're the goat this
is your chance yeah yeah no no problem I
mean it's just Michael Jordan right we
must destroy that which stands in our
way the media dare show that kind of
frustration in front of sir Jordan it's
like blood in the water who what I cut
away all your distractions cut away
self-doubt and security once you have
removed all that does not serve you in
battle you found your mom before my
fellow gods of tomorrow we are the dream
James Knight
[Applause]
this is the previous battle I've ever
seen
what's the chainmail
dog
he's mine hole abroad now I've waited
for this take it in because this is your
last
good farmer
spare some wine for your goat okay don't
drink wine huh
I mean me King James the now undisputed
greatest knight of all time nobody's
better than Michael Jordan well you know
I defeated him save the realm no big
deal
okay is that LeBron James Jory's what's
he won just a little celebratory wine is
all he says he's better than Sir Jordan
it's true actually oh come on
Jordan's got six rings Jordan tequila
never lost the final oh he says he beat
him it's a big battle okay well Jordans
like 60 so gives a [ __ ] well actually he
was in his prime because he used magic
soul box Shaw's on the Dream Team and
have you not heard of any of this now
we'll check your highlight Ravens
haven't gotten any what about your local
sports crier no no no reason nothing
social media Ravens have been down for a
while to wait so you're telling me we
just had the biggest most epic battle in
the history of the realm and nobody
heard about it
guess not what oh now this is great
finally we can just play basketball
no blog boys around to criticize us we
got no haters in the stands
yeah it's um it's nice bit boring though
realm official everyone just be cool
Kairi stock I know these dudes
LeBron what have you done
you saved the realm I liberated it you
didn't have to burn it all down you
destroyed everything the stats the
history the stories gossip the ignorant
critiques the unfounded trade rumors
through all I've done for you I finally
beat sir Jordan and now there's no media
down to talk about it so that's what
this is about that I've spoiled your
coronation ceremony don't be fooled Sir
Anthony his whole selfless teammate act
is just that an act behind those corny
dad jokes is an insatiable appetite for
adoration Perry you must understand that
with the media del in shambles there is
nobody to generate interest in our
battles our ratings are dim our economy
is failing every second a family isn't
obsessing on Ben's image trade rumors or
r.j. Barrett's progress is one they are
spending exploring other passions like
science philosophy or even worse
spending time with their families what
can I say guess I ruined something else
we're going to have to suspend you
indefinitely for this but considering
you are a star Knight we would be
willing to commute your sentence if you
and your crew of grumpy boys agreed to
rebuild the media tell you've still got
so much potential curry
don't waste it sulking here in the dark
don't tell me what to do I'm not your
sidekick anymore
very well
burn down the media Dell there what
hello I have burned down a few things in
my day okay like what
how sixes maester hinky how long have
you been down here Oh quite some time
the only thing that sustains me is
knowing that somewhere beyond those bars
Joelle and beed Ben Simmons and I assume
Jason Tatum are now a dynasty tell me
how many championships have we won Oh
what I'd give for the chance to show the
world I can do more than just burn
things down telling me about its
destruction is the easy part
any cynic can tear things down and call
themselves a genius but it takes a true
visionary to actually improve things to
build a better world that's the part I
was really looking forward to that's the
real challenge so now you want us to
just rebuild this place what about your
whole rant about haters I gotta say
being in the dungeon for almost a day it
really changed me I realized the haters
are what fuel us without conflict there
is no story and our realm is as much
about the stories as the battles
themselves
okay well also if we don't rebuild this
we won't be rich anymore I have to get
real jobs so what do we do Russ you
throw up bricks from a distance
Kevin collect all your burners and start
repopulating the Raven read draymond
you're the guy on the construction site
that yells at everybody Jimmy you're
also that guy Gogi you'll handle the
engineering and blueprints would why me
because you've got vast experience with
technicals swamp dragon you'll be doing
the welding and mellow you're on the
bench oh come on
I'm good again
I gotta say Kyrie I'm impressed it's a
top to mediate a long time there's one
last thing to do all the books and
histories of this realm were destroyed
in the fire
they must be rewritten let the truth
fill these books
ladies and gentlemen of boleros we are
here to bestow upon King James the most
exalted title of goat of goats for he
hath lettuce Knights to victory against
the foe once believed unbeatable the
dream team in doing so he defeated prime
Michael Jordan earning him the title of
the greatest knight of all time
hashtag wash King yeah thank you
everyone but the day isn't really about
me it's about my teammates it's about
all the legends who came before me
of course the Fanning's the media dell
masters and the future goats who may one
day take this crown from me
thank you now before we officially
crowned King James are there any
objections
[Music]
Jordan I mean you could make the case
LeBron got lucky you know yeah I mean I
was at the battle and don't get me wrong
the bran was incredible but it was only
one battle best-of-seven put my money on
Jordan what I don't know I got a
disagree with you Chuck I think now
these guys finally beat the dream team I
think that's all the evidence I need to
say that the goat it's gotta be Tatum
right it's gotta be what Jason Tatum has
everyone gone mad where's Nik right I
think the dragon got him now hold on
everyone I am lucky enough to witness
King James's greatness night in and
night out what he does at his age is
truly unprecedented thank you that being
said what one could argue he's not even
the best knight on his own team well now
hold on the numbers cannot be denied I
have amassed the most points of any
knight in history also six rings
I have a seven reasons why I am the goat
I would get LeBrons
us this debate is over I am the ghost
but let me ask you this what does the
word goat mean to you anyway what makes
a goat is it the Rings is it the stats
is it the style no it's the story
there's nothing more powerful than a
good story and who has a better story
then Paul Pierce what hole Pierce not
only has a championship ring and was a
10 time all-star but he did it all after
being stabbed he once hit a game-winning
bank shot and when asked if he called
Bank he said I called game
a crippled man who became the most
interesting Meister in the media Dell
when he had the courage say he was
better than Dwyane Wade right he's right
about something that Chad over Al
Harrington was all time to Paul Pierce
the true goat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]